[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'anciens par
les sports votre talk sur le sport local
pour ce dernier numéro de l'année à 2017
et oui déjà il y aura comme d'habitude
des analyses des débats et des duels
acharnés entre nos experts sur
l'actualité sportive du département
pendant près d'une heure pour cette
dernière nous avons décidé de faire une
thématique spéciale fêtes de fin d'année
nos quatre chroniqueurs se sont donc mis
sur leur trente-et-un présentation en
musique on commence à ma droite c'est un
peu l'emblème de cette émission sur le
pouvait on le mettrait tout en haut de
notre sapin de noël sur pv ce sera 18
comme toujours il sera très généreux en
punch line et en blagues pendant cette
émission l'ex entraîneur de plaisir le
mythes et légendes l'unique genlis est
avec nous pour cette émission toujours
genre et bonjour à tous très beaux
déguisements et c'était thématique noël
donc un joyeux noël avant bien sûr voilà
vous les garder pendant toute l'émission
a bien sûr et bien sûr mais sûre que
vous avez une petite cravate
ah oui je sais pas si on l'entend bien
vive le vent voilà vous le lac ce n'est
pas trop peu non
en tout cas vous laisse vous avez ramené
des blagues dans votre vote
non non non non non jamais je vous le
dis c'est pas moi c'est une somme et mes
coéquipiers que la kangoo qui font les
nbc le point d'accord pas vous on passe
à ma gauche un musique c'est un peu le
cadeau qu'on a toujours voulu avoir
c'est notre petit flocon de neige sur ce
plateau
mais attention sous ses airs de mère
noël ne fera pas de cadeau aux autres
chroniqueurs notre ambassadrice de
charme
hélène de la grange spécialiste de pole
dance à versailles est avec nous bonjour
élèves
bonjour c'est charmant cette petite
présentation ah oui ça va alors c'est
pareil pour vous spécial fêtes de fin
d'année oui voila je me suis allé me
faire un petit peu changé un peu
d'habitude mais je franchement je
chapeau à agent miss c'est fantastique
ans elle travaille
on repasse à droite un musique sous son
apparence de petits lutins se cache le
cerveau du sport yvelinois c'est l'homme
le plus brillant du département si vous
vouliez acheter une encyclopédie à vos
enfants pour noël
j'ai mieux à vous proposer frederick
henderson le professeur le directeur
sportif des templiers d'elancourt
bonjour frédéric bonjour à tous alors
vous êtes le cadeau idéal pour noël si
les enfants veulent apprendre j'espère
que les électeurs s'ils ont été sages
espère qu'ils ont quelques jouets quoi
est-ce que vous êtes libre avec ses
piles toujours des gens qu on termine à
ma gauche à musique malgré sa carrure de
rugbyman une âme d'enfant sommeille en
lui noël et sa période préférée à de la
neige au pied du sapin le 25 décembre ce
passionné du ballon ovale a dû écrire en
père noël pour avoir des maillots de
rugby je suppose au coude et ballon
piqué au bal je suis donc
or nous sommes avec pierre chevalier du
club de rugby de versailles pour
classifier communication ancien joueur
du club
oui tout à fait voilà un très beau
chapeau merci dans la thématique bon
vous êtes on sait n'aime pas qu'on
supprime non pas du tout mais vous
n'êtes pas concertés niveau certes les
boules du thym du père noël
on verra sûrement émissions et j'aime
bien être sur la bûche alors on en
discutera après l'émission
on va passer à maintenant au programme
de l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de handball féminin un match de
coupe d'europe sera organisé au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
au mois de février prochain
nous évoquerons également les plus
grands moments du sport évinois qui ont
ponctué cette année à 2017 mais avant de
développer ces thèmes nous allons
plonger dans une performance d'apnée
[Musique]
nous commençons donc par une performance
à couper le souffle celle d'andry dandy
cabreira avila ce franco cubain de 46
ans réussit le dimanche 10 décembre à
repousser encore un peu plus les limites
du corps humain pendant ce week-end du
téléthon dans la piscine aqua mundo de
saint-cyr-l'ecole le maître nageur a
réalisé 53,3 150 km en faisant des
longueur en apnée pendant 24 heures
il a à pulvériser le record de près de
17 km pour réussir cet exploit
l'apnéiste n'a pas dormi pendant toute
la durée de la performance le champion
nous explique les difficultés qu'il a
rencontrées au micro de tv 78 c'est des
petites craintes prévient etc et en
douane fait attention à l'intensité des
ménages parce que si un club arrive
après le s'arrêter et donc ça s'est
ralenti
donc c'est pour ça que je m'arrête tous
les vingt longues heures pendant une
minute deux minutes ça répond le temps
de natation des neiges et je m'hydrate
avec des lots avec de l'eau et des chocs
hard et celle des datations orale et
avec thibaut du bicarbonate
il faut hydrater tout le temps de temps
son record pourrait être enregistrée au
guinness book des records sa performance
a permis de récolter plus de 1000 euros
en faveur du téléthon
là également à nager avec un aileron de
dauphins dans les derniers mètres pour
dénoncer la captivité des dauphins dans
léa parc aquatique
encore un grand bravo à andy cabreira
avila la question sur ce thème
ce record est il incroyable vous votez
oui non oui non si elle entre les
pierres explosés jean genre pourquoi
vous avez voté non parce que tout le
monde a dit oui
[Rires]
non bien sûr que c'est incroyable mais
je dis que non parce que en un point
commun tous les deux moi aussi je fais
des apnées du sommeil et je m'arrête
simplement pour aller pisser
oui et je laisse des records parce qu'il
s'est arrêté pour aller aux toilettes je
précise donc bons ballons sont encore en
un seul arrêt en 24 heures sienne des
seuls à dire qu'ils sont dans la piscine
pour l'auto la tenait bon c'est pas tout
non bien sûr que c'est sérieux ce genre
de poésie du positif pour moi mais je
suis aussi une performance sportive
énorme je suis pas capable de juger
cette performance physique telle qu'elle
est pas ce qu on dit que c'est son nez
longueur de 25 mètres qui s'arrête
toutes les quatre longueurs il peine à
une minute il avait du père alors oui
c'est certainement une grande
performance mais ça va pas aller plus
loin quoi comme et la soeur de bouchons
et l'autre balle c'est pareil ce mardi
elle trouve que lacombe le combiné de la
performance entre l'apnée est le les
longueurs et elles sont assez est assez
incroyable
le fait de non seulement les non
seulement il est il est sous l'eau ici
de 20 longueurs vingt longues heures
d'affilée en nageant c'est ça que je
trouve trop assez assez étonnant et
assez assez le tout avec un chrono avec
une montre dont ils emportent tout son
expression reprendre les exemples du
grand bleu et des différents records
d'apnée c'est partant profondeur ils
nagent assez peu
il ya ceux qui restent aussi au fond au
fond d'une piscine ou au fond d'un d'un
boyau fond d'une piscine ou de la mère
lui avait biffé des longueurs des
longueurs de piscine il en fait vingt
ils s'arrêtent un petit peu il repart
tout ça pendant 53 km c'est assez
édifiant et d'aller vers ça même sans
rappeler la performance était
impressionnante paire 53 km ne pas
s'arrêter pendant 24 heures
c'est vrai que ba chapeau à lui surtout
que c'était pour la bonne cause
la licence en l1 est pour vous un record
je ne sais pas si c'est un record mais
c'est quand même extraordinaire car
auxerre moi je ne le ferais pas et pas
en 24 heures il me faut plus que ça pour
quoi peut-être sur la semaine je le
ferai mais mes patients 24 heures donc
déjà en soi et par dessus on rajoute le
fait de les faire en apnée ça reste
quand même moi j'ai pas compris ils
felipe les pins à la suite sans respirer
où ils respirent agi fait une longueur
il attendra que m il respire der par
l'ong à 25 mètres il respire et ainsi de
suite face à pau a atteint un nouveau
record pour les vins sont respectés à
son prochain record et alors ils
voulaient réaliser hélène à la base 42
km avec les entraînements qu'il a fait
finalement il a pulvérisé ce record
voilà il en est à 53,3 150 bien au delà
moi je trouve ça extraordinaire comme on
lisait entre ont déjà le fait de nager
sans s'arrêter pendant 24 heures c'est
énorme je peux imaginer l'entraînement
derrière l'apnée déjà aussi pareil c'est
énorme et les deux combinés je peux même
pas envisagé
je ne vois pas comment c'est possible de
tenir
oui 53 et quelques kilomètres comme ça
on respire en une minute tout les toutes
les toutes les longueurs c'est c'est moi
je trouve ça extraordinaire wall dance
j'avais d'apnée pendant inversis on peut
pas réfléchir se concentrer respirer
donc déjà oui on fait un peu datés mais
d'un neurone en fait mais enfin c'est
rien de comparable fils mba le prochain
record tandis cabreira alors pour
préparer ce record en dix parties à cuba
pour s'entraîner mais il a également
réalisé de multiples l'entraînement
depuis septembre à saint cyr l'école on
écoute dépouillé ma septembre j'ai
commencé à m'entraîner
de façon spécifique à cette prof dame
blanche longue et combine l'amener à sic
et l'amener dans l'eau avec des petits
palme des fois des séries et des quais
durdaine tellement qu'elle dure 2h 3h
avec des ddd travail des minimes majeur
pour l ai fait mon état de fatigue pour
ajuster les paramètres près la candeur
scène c'est digne d'un entraînement de
haut niveau on peut le dire ça fait de
toute façon la performance la
performance temps extraordinaire on
imagine le travail qu'il ya derrière qui
est aussi hors norme c'est pas la portée
de tout le monde et surtout pas
n'importe qui donc on s'est vraiment
chapeau l'artiste
vous avez déjà fait d'appeler autour de
cette table vous pierre chevalier non en
vacances en vacances exactement pour
aller chercher trois coquillages ça se
résume à je pense de mettre au fond de
l'eau et puis un beau faciès double où
tout rouge pour remonter mais
certainement pas à ces niveaux de de
pratiques d'entraînement et de
performance surtout pour la bonne cause
colisée commises et fred je crois que ça
se limite à compter jusqu'à 30 ou 50 et
à porter de l'eau coiffer c'est très
compliqué en plus cela venait c'est très
compliqué parce que il ya le phénomène
le phénomène de panique au fond quand on
commence à se retenir de respirer il
s'installe avec deux phénomènes de
panique on avoir fait un petit peu quand
j'étais jeune
vous avez fait car ni sun et du coup on
pense à quoi quand on est dans l'eau
mais justement il ya un canadien dans
l'adaptation
à ce nouvel élément qui est qui est
important avant et pour faire le vide et
ensuite pouvoir pouvoir contrôler sa
respiration je peux dire et pour se
détendre le plus possible pour rester un
maximum et il est passé et d'ailleurs
j'avais avalé quelques litres d'eau j'ai
gardé la fresnaye qu'anderson je le
disais tout à l'heure son record c'était
pour une bonne cause le téléthon
également pour la protection des
dauphins est ce qu'on pense à ça aussi
peut-être qu'on est dans l'eau est ce
que ça motive encore plus du coup dans
une performance sportive d'avoir un but
comme le téléthon monsieur des
complémentaires le faire pour quelqu'un
d'autre plutôt que le faire pour soi
plutôt que d'un petit plaisir égoïste de
d'inscrire son nom sur sur un palmarès
où sur une liste de records c'est
toujours je pense que c'est toujours
plus motivant et c'est plus gratifiant
une fois qu'on a réussi à accomplir
accomplir ce genre de record vous pensez
qu'il peut à venir encore son record
pierre 6 lip6 pensé faire 42 kg mais
qu'il en fait 53 alors il ya peut-être
une motivation la motivation téléthon
aux bonnes causes
mais oui on peut sûrement pensé cic ans
je sais pas combien de temps il s'est
entraîné pour cette performance précise
mais a pris 3,4 4e manche ici les
raisons pour lesquelles il a arrêté
il aurait peut-être pu motiver ce
bulletin voilà un homme sait pas
pourquoi
quelle raison il a précisé qu'il s'était
fixé qu'après 24 heures d'accès 24
heures si ça se trouve on leur posait la
question se trouve une rupture les
bloquons connaissez ça il avait réalisé
six heures il ya deux ans 12 heures les
dernières 24 heures cette année 48
heures 48 heures de l'année prochaine
peut-être donc au régime
la grisonne il a 46 ans alors après son
record nous allons parler d'une autre
performance mais cette fois ci en
football du football donc et de la coupe
de france où le club de r3 s'est
brillamment qualifié pour les 32e de
finale de la compétition en s'imposant
contre le club guyanais de l'ess matoury
une équipe qui évolue deux divisions au
dessus des yvelinois le score 2 buts à 1
et il était évidemment ravi de cette
performance on regarde cet extrait
hélène superbe ambiance
oui ils ont l'air d'avoir concours pas
mal d'énergie à la fin du match donc son
prêt pour le tour succès ça voilà alors
le tirage au sort justement il a déjà eu
lieu et où il affrontera n'affrontera
pas un club de ligue 1 dans un club de
national une concarneau cinq divisions
d'écart la rencontre aura lieu le 6
janvier prochain
normalement à domicile dans leur stade
maurice baquet la question sur ce thème
est ce que c'est un bon tirage pour hui
d'affronter une nationale quand carlos
est ce que c'est un bon tirage
oui ou non est ce que c'est un tirage
favorable pour un bon tirage favorable
je ne sais pas oui oui bon c'est tout ce
que vous êtes indécis
de votre côté jean enfin un petit duel
encore le retour entre bière et jean
pierre les sportifs sportivement je
pense que c'est un bon tirage parce qu'
il vaut mieux jouer
pas trop éloigné de ses divisions ses
divisions de d'habitude en revanche
après sur l'événement la coupe de france
est à l'étude compétition fantastique
justement fait jouer la france entière
et tous les niveaux et a priori la
plupart des clubs même affronté des
clubs mieux classés plus prestigieux est
accroché à son tableau de chasse
justement sur un tableau de coupe de
france
un gros de d2 2e de ligue 1
bon je pense que sportivement
sportivement c'est plus à leur portée de
taper concarneau que d'aller cinq
divisions d'écart quand même qu'en mai
et bien sûr où il sera le petit poucet
la compétition c'est ça qui est beau
c'est ça qui est beau dans le foot
français qui est fantastique si on
compare par rapport à au rugby il y
avait il y avait le yves du manoir qui
existait il ya quelques années avec des
affrontements entre des équipes de pro
d2 à l'époque et de et de groupe ares en
première division
la la la la magie de cette cette
compétition c'est justement de réunir
l'ensemble des footballeurs des
footballs du de l'amateur au
professionnel et donc le petit poucet
peut se faire sa place malgré tout genre
vous étiez partager savez j'étais
partagé justement c'est un bon tirage
pour oui oui alors c'est ce que je
voulais dire exactement j'étais partagé
parce que sportivement il vaut mieux
qu'ils prennent une équipe quand même
autre fait une équipe comme ça de ce
niveau parce que cinq divisions et 10
d'écart entre les deux mais je sais
qu'il rêvait certainement de jouer une
ligue 1 quoi leur rêve c'était le psg
et voilà on rêve le derby dans les
yvelines qui joue pas il ya encore des
grandes pointures et le monaco je crois
encore dans cette compétition il ya tous
les clubs de ligue 1 voilà sans les
clubs de ligue 1 sont donc certainement
que leur rêve c'était ça mais
sportivement s'ils veulent encore
espérer figurer au prochain tour et
c'est là la magie de la coupe de france
on a parlé plusieurs fois autour de
cette table c'est la marche de la magie
de la coupe de france de football
c'est que justement tout le monde tout
le monde peut battre tout le monde et
que la voiture est certainement pas
terminée pour fredrik andersson votre
avis concarneau est actuellement 13e du
championnat de national une donc c'est
pas non plus une équipe qui domine son
championnat à fond ils ont un bilan de 3
victoires 5 nuls et sept défaites depuis
le début de la saison
finalement ils sont peut-être prenable
pour lui pas du tout elles sont cinq
divisions au dessus je passe ce sont des
professionnels en national mais ça peut
ça tape à la porte là la ligue 2 donc
ils sont professionnels
donc déjà déjà la différence entre un
club amateur et un club professionnel
bas les moyens la mise en oeuvre au
niveau de l'entraînement le rythme les
capacités physiques
je pense que sportivement quel que soit
le tirage qu'ils auraient eu ça a été un
match compliqué après il faut savoir ce
qu'ils veulent et ce qu'ils veulent
aller plus loin sportivement ou est ce
qu'il est ce qu'il rêvait d'avoir un
gros match pour terminer sur sur un
événement un peu extraordinaire histoire
de réaliser un rêve de jouer contre une
équipe de ligue 1 qu'ils ont peut-être
pas l'occasion de leur faire de si tôt
parce que c'est vrai que quand on voit
des petits pouces est arrivé au stade le
plus élevé de la compétition
d'une année sur l'autre c'est jamais le
même petit poucet 1 c'est toujours c'est
toujours un autre club qui arrive à se
faire sa place peut-être un peu de
chance un peu une année exceptionnelle
on ne sait pas ce qui peut se passer
c'est vrai que - mesure où il avance
dans la compétition il ya de moins en
moins de place place à la chance et
d'aider bon tirage en a de moins en
moins quand on est quand on est le
maillon faible quelques pas un peu le
petit poucet de la compétition
pour info où il a déjà réussi à
atteindre les seizièmes de finale en
à l'époque il y avait deux coupes de
france celle de la zone libre et celle
de la zone occupée où il y avait perdu 2
0 contre reims finalement finalement
c'était il ya bien longtemps je suis pas
sûr c'est bien c'est bien trop de liens
avec avec la compétition d'aujourd'hui
et puis on voit bien que le sport a
évolué de façon dramatique dramatique de
façon extraordinaire au cours des
dernières décennies n'ont que déjà même
si on prend le football d'aujourd'hui le
football il ya dix ans c'est déjà plus
le même football alors on imagine bien
que en 1940 c'était plus c'était encore
des ballons nivellement juste les vessie
de porc qu'on tapait avec le pied droit
c'est milan déjà fait oui on en reste là
enfin c'est pas utile on fait ça vous
connaît pas activement du père qu'ils
ont du goût joueurs depuis l'école
hélène sur la question et c'est un bon
tirage pour mouiller à presser
c'est aussi l'occasion de déclarer de
l'expérience et de travailler mais je
pense que comme tu le disais les deux
les deux tirages aurait de toute façon
était assez compliqué c'est des
adversaires de taille des doigts qui
l'appliqué pas là après c'était c'est ce
que l'on va voir le résultat
c'est ça la magie de la coupe de france
alors ils vont sûrement jouer à domicile
je le disais précédemment en début
d'après midi et non le soir car le stade
et non homologuée pour jouer le soir à
cause de l'éclairage le terrain
forcément sera un peu plus champêtre on
peut le dire que les les terrains de
national
est ce que ça peut jouer dans résultat
final du match pierre ça joue au moins
dans le dans la partie circonstances on
parlait de cette magie de la coupe de
france et c'est vraiment c'est c'est
vraiment l'état l'âge des différences
qui peut y avoir entre différents clubs
différentes divisions
là on est dans un club qui doit être a
priori sans éclairage au sens où sans
tribune homologué dans tous les cas sage
ça jouera sa jouera sur la vertu à
domicile yves rossy reçoivent sur leur
terrain qu'ils connaissent bien
on parlait de l'esprit de l'esprit des
clubs amateurs ça là oui ça fait partie
des repères qui peuvent jouer en leur
faveur même si c'est sans sans éclairage
ou c'est en début d'après midi
c'est peut-être mieux aussi éclairage
naturel et je pense qu'ils sont plus
habitués à jouer sur un terrain comme
celui là et dans leur division ils sont
plus habitués à jouer dans l'après midi
que le soir et ça je pense que ça ça
joue sajou également leurs fèves
vous êtes d'accord sur le terrain qui
peut jouer en leur faveur
oui tout à fait tout à fait à ce niveau
là
ils ont l'habitude ils ont l'habitude de
leur thérèse ont leurs repères et
forcément plus ils ont leur public chose
où je pense pas que les gens vont se
déplacer à concarneau fille si c'était
là bas quoi je pense pas qu'ils aient
vraiment énormément énormément de
supporters qu'ils les suivent donc un
étage chez eux ils auront ils seront
plus à même d'attirer du monde proche et
de faire venir du public pour les
soutenir quoi sera plus ce sera mieux ce
sera il faut il faut il faut y à il ya
eu m la mairie de dingue pour qu' il
faut que le maire douille se bougent
quoi à noter accords 2006 l'actuel
entraîneur douilles
franck blankenship avait réussi à sortir
avec son ancienne formation du chéné
l'équipe de sannois saint gratien alors
en national ça peut jouer également pour
les commerçants
l'entraîneur l'a déjà fait il l'a déjà
fait après c'est dansant sur le terrain
donc c'est toujours pareil après les ont
peut-être une chance jouer sur l'effet
de surprise peut-être que concarneau à
venir avec déjà match gagné
peut-être que le terrain peut-être que
l'ambiance peut-être quelque chose va
pas contribuer à les faire déjouer c'est
peut-être la chance douilles de de
pouvoir saisir
ben c'est une attention essayer de créer
la surprise et l'événement prochaine
fois je vous de la fin sur ce thème on
passe maintenant un autre sport
collectif nous allons parler de handball
féminin vous après avoir accueilli un
match de championnat en 2016 entre issy
paris et brest le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines va accueillir
le 3 février à prochain une rencontre de
coupe d'europe
ici paris affrontera l'équipe
norvégienne devises peur christiane
cents au quatrième tour de la
compétition
ce sera donc le deuxième rendez vous
organisé au vélodrome par les dirigeants
parisiens
on écoute les réactions des choses ça va
être très sympa
l'année dernière nous avons vu contre
brest et c'était génial de jouer au
vélodrome
il y avait beaucoup de monde et une très
bonne ambiance
c'était une belle expérience ce match
est spécial pour moi parce que je vais
jouer contre une équipe de mon pays j'ai
beaucoup d'amis là j'ai joué avec
certaines rues et poutrelles dans
différentes équipes
c'est une super idée puisque ça permet
aussi d'aller chercher un peu de public
ailleurs et voilà de les fidéliser
al club par contre c'est vrai que c'est
un peu compliqué pour les jeux qu'on a
une petite habitude joue à domicile
voilà mais bon moi je trouve que si on
arrive à gagner du public après si on
arrive à les fidéliser et qui viennent
nous voir au palais des sports d'issy
les moulineaux
par la suite ça peut être vraiment une
bonne idée la question sur ce thème
une bonne idée de retenter l'expérience
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines est ce que
c'est une bonne idée oui ou non
oui oui oui vous êtes tous unanimes et
l'aide
oui toute façon le
on a déjà eu un précédent si ça peut
permettre de
va te faire encore plus connaître
vraiment dans le coin c'est elles sont
juste à côté c'est vraiment le lieu
local après on verra bien ce que ça
donne mais je pense que ça va faire
venir du monde et ça a bien marché
dernière fois donc 5000 personnes
schefferville la dernière fois bah
espérons que cette année ce soit la même
famille grand père saad mais si vous
étiez quoi je pense que c'est une bonne
chose pas davantage qu'ils ont c'est
qu'en plus bas en plus du sport qui est
assez populaire le handball féminin en
plus en ce moment c'est là c'est
d'époque 1 c'est la compétition
internationale ça permet d'intéresser
les gens au handball féminin et tout ce
qui permet d'attirer l'attention c'est
une bonne chose et en plus ils vont
pouvoir aussi espérer pouvoir profiter
du dur nom de la structure parce que
c'est vrai que le vélodrome de saint
quentin c'est un bel ouvrage et mêmes ne
serait ce que par curiosité peut-être
que les gens seront intéressés de voir
commencer à l'intérieur et en plus du
beau spectacle
ça permet de remplir et puis l'intéressé
comme comme disait la joueuse si après
ça permet de créer des nouveaux fans
pour les venir les voir jouer à issy les
moulineaux
c'est tout bénef pour elle le prix des
places se sera pas forcément très cher 8
euros en prévente 5 euros pour les
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines
il y aura des packs aussi qui seront
acquis seront vendus pas cher du tout
est ce que c'est c'est positif justement
de vue j'ai pris aussi bas pour attirer
le civic d'harris interactive savas
accessible ça permet de devenir à
plusieurs avec les enfants etc
donc je pense que pour remplir le stade
suivant une bonne chose et puis ça
permet de générer un peu de trésorerie
et puis c'est vrai que ça fait jamais de
mal à toutes les actions sont les
associations sportives de récupérer un
peu d'argent en plus pour bat pour
financer d'autres actions qui peuvent
avoir en parallèle ne serait ce que sur
les jeunes du club
ça serait bien aussi que puissent en
bénéficier si c'est possible
vous avez un petit message pierre et oui
oui je suis très admiratif et très
emballé justement par le parlement pour
leur montrer voilà
c'est en deux ballons très très
admiratif de l'engouement qui tourne
autour du handball masculin et féminin
depuis quelques années on est on est
deux très belles équipes de franceschi
c'est ce qui nous manque dans dans
certains sports et et notamment dans le
handball féminin là il ya une vraie une
vraie particularité une vraie une vraie
identité de ce sport l'un des défis qui
en parle bien des filles qui sont
enthousiastes en ce moment l'équipe de
france performent bien
après sa victoire contre le monténégro
et la jouer la carte d'un d'un match de
coupe d'europe un beau match
international sur le territoire c'est
c'est de toute façon participé à ce gros
feux d'artifice et a7 à cet emballement
justement du handball du handball
féminin dont je pense que c'est un joli
coup je ne sais pas qui est à
l'initiative qui sait les clubs si c'est
le souci c'est la fédération d'ici paris
il ya la demande qui va être votre
élitiste qui va faire un petit peu de
séduction dans l'ensemble des
départements limitrophes
je pense que c'est une bonne idée c'est
ça doit être ça doit être copiés dans
beaucoup de sports
si en plus ça se recueillent l'agrément
du public et puis on fait un guichet
fermé à chaque fois tout le monde gagne
vous êtes pour ou contre autour de cette
table sur la délocalisation des clubs
dans d'autres salles comme comme le
boulodrome jean vous par exemple dans la
mesure où s'ils n'ont pas la capacité
d'accueillir autant de spectateurs
est ce que les joueurs s'en plaignait
dans l'interview
sont pas forcément leurs repères on peut
dire je ne sais pas où elle joue
d'habitude mais
ça joue à issy les moulineaux la salle
contient combien 1000 places et voilà
une personne de là c'est cinq fois plus
yahya jammeh c c'est bien de faire venir
de faire déplacer des gens et de remplir
des stades et des salles de tous sports
confondus c'est toujours bien c'est
toujours un plus et puis yann dujarrier
doit doit rêver de voir le vélodrome
rempli pour la compétition il ya nigeria
qui est le pistard de vélizy 78 kg et
chroniqueur ici sûr si on part lesparre
et qu'il n'est pas présent
malheureusement aujourd'hui il paraît
que vous le faire un tour
vélo pendant la juan part d'analystes
alors il y aura une chose à qui ça fera
forcément plaisir ce match contre ces
norvégienne c'est victoria alaric la
gardienne de 20 ans d'ici paris qui a
joué à voisin retenu pendant deux ans et
à montigny le bretonneux pendant trois
ans elle est évidemment ravi de revenir
dans sa ville
wait see repasse jeu voir les copains
les copines mais oui ça reste le premier
club important donc ça compte
donc c'est que les supporters de saint
quentin sont sympas chaleureux il met du
bruit donc il ya moins que ça mais c'est
une grosse grosse ambiance super
histoire hélène de cette jeune fille
jeune joueuse en plus elle est la nôtre
à domicile elle est enjouée elle est
content de revenir elle connaît les
supporters comme elle disait et je pense
que mon bien sûr ça va changer leurs
petites habitudes leurs salles et cetera
maintenant elles sont dans un lieu qui
va aussi créer un certain engouement
toute une ambiance
moment de la rencontre et je pense que
ça peut les emmener vraiment à mieux
performer à gagner et du coup à faire
encore plus connaître et donc elle
serait encore plus ravi de voir voir
cette ambiance là qui va se recrée
qu'elle connaît déjà d'ailleurs avec
anderson cette délocalisation justement
ça permet ce type d'histoire puis et
puis je conseille salaire ça les
perturbe plus que ça puisque de base de
match déjà c'est pas un match comme les
autres donc te par l'événement lui-même
sait déjà c'est déjà quelque chose
exceptionnelle moi je sais qu'avec les
temples et quand on avait des pas quand
on joue des matchs en saison régulière
on les joue à la clé saint pierre et
quand on avait les matches de coupe
d'europe on allait jouer à guy boniface
le fait de changer même on changer
carrément de surface de jeu puisque à la
clé sa place du synthétique les ailes à
guy boniface à elancourt ccc de l'herbe
ça nous a jamais empêché de jouer
correctement même si on n'avait pas nos
repères de l'habitude le jeu ça reste le
même les stratégistes à restent les
mêmes il suffit juste de jouer et puis
d'essayer de remporter la victoire
ça sera le mot de la fin encore une fois
pour vous frederick henderson a pressé
le coup de projecteur place à notre
focus du jour
une fois n'est pas coutume nous allons
parler de tome ligne dans cette émission
un sport dérivé de la gymnastique ultra
spectaculaire il se pratique sur une
piste de 25 m le but est de réaliser
huit mouvements rebondissant est l'un
des meilleurs clubs de france et basés
aux clayes-sous-bois enlevant mois
dernier l'un des athlètes du club
axel duriez 12 ans remporté en novembre
donc la médaille de bronze au
championnat du monde par groupe d'âge à
sofia en bulgarie on écoute les
réactions alors est ce que cette
médaille de bronze était attendu
rené attendu espéré
parce que attendu c'est pour voir que
c'est le tout le gratin mondial qui se
retrouvent à cette compétition
le niveau est très relevé je n'ai jamais
eu de médaille internationale
de toute ma carrière avec mes athlètes
donc je savais qu'elle avait des grandes
capacités parce qu'il a fait une sortie
internationale donc de fin septembre et
octobre au portugal où il a raflé la
médaille d'or mais ce n'était qu'un
tournoi
tout le monde n'était pas là une super
performance donc mais malheureusement
cette performance n'est pas passée n'est
passé sur aucune chaîne nationale la
question sur ce thème ce sport est il
trop confidentielle pierre moi je vais
vous faire un aveu c'est que c'est
qu'avant de à vendre deux de lire les
différents les différentes lignes sur
ceux sur cette émission là je ne
connaissais même pas le les tenants et
les aboutissants de ce sport là donc ça
m'a permis justement le cultiver un
petit peu et d'apprendre d'apprendre une
nouvelle discipline donc oui forcément
forcément est malheureusement trop trop
confidentielle théologique on n'en parle
pas sur les chaînes nationales
ça nous aider avec des choix justes des
choix éditoriaux
est ce que est ce que c'est déjà un
sport pratiqué par beaucoup est ce que
c'est
est ce qu'il ya des skis à des sponsors
est ce qu'il ya des est ce qui est
beaucoup d'équipés nationales et des
représentants nationaux un peu partout
là on a priori un titre et ça passe ça
passe complètement à la semaine il y
aura peu duré que quinze mille
pratiquants en france
une déviation une variante de plusieurs
disciplines et du cou puis on et
variantes de variantes bon on en parle
aussi moyen d'adhérents donc même si on
a un super résultat et des athlètes de
haut niveau parce que ce niveau là on
est en athlé en athlète de haut niveau
je pense qu'il ya pas assez de
visibilité en parle pas assez on il n'ya
pas ses loyers d'adhérents de deux
rencontres première on va parler de tout
c'est toujours l'éternel problème des
disciplines on peut pas parler de tout
ce que sinon il faudrait parler toute la
journée tellement il ya des disciplines
je suis et je rejoins pierre jeu là vous
je connaissais pas du tout cette
discipline je la connaissais pas du tout
mais au même titre
j'ai un exemple tu gélules sur les
réseaux sociaux dernièrement on a un
athlète français qui est qui a été pour
la 24e fois championne du monde de
planche à voile dans le sud ouest et
dont on n'a jamais entendu parler de la
télévision il a 24 titres de championne
du monde et on n'en parle pas donc alors
c'est sûr alors dans leur discipline et
c'est une performance
mais malheureusement on est dans une
société où et on ne parle que des sports
qui intéressent et qui font qu'ils font
de l'argent alors aux homicides de les
rendre intéressant enfin voila c'est
donc c'est dommage de sportivement mais
malheureusement c'est comme ça et on
pourra régner alors c'est une discipline
quand même qui a été aux jeux olympiques
mais en 1932 à los angeles et ça sera la
seule fois que ce sport sera pratiquée
aux jeux olympiques ça joue forcément
sur la popularité a atteint sport ça
joue du point de vue des bas de
l'attention qu'on obtient c'est vrai que
les années olympiques c'est vraiment un
gros coup de projecteur pour de
nombreuses fédérations vient justement
du mal à obtenir un peu un peu
d'attention médiatique et c'est une
problématique on a souvent discuté ici
sur le plateau là il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas de place pour tout le monde que des
gens comme des pierres et c'est vrai
qu'au final c'est les sports où il ya le
plus d'argent qu'ils peuvent investir
dans la communication
et c'est vrai que quand on n'a pas ces
moyens là pour pour essayer d'attirer
l'attention du des gens bas on reste
dans l'anonymat malgré les performances
hors du commun qu'on peut qu'on peut
produire et c'est vrai que c'est un peu
dommage qu'on ne le sport passe au
second plan et et qu'on est là à
discuter de problèmes de communication
d'attention une médiatisation
pourquoi votre alesi bière quand je le
quand je le vois là sûrement sûrement
sur une démonstration sur un os que jo
est un parking de centre commercial et
autres sûrement pour justement essayer
de
de montrer un peu les discipline
popularisée ça me rappelle certaines
certain moment un petit peu moins fastes
qu'on a pu avoir sur le golf par exemple
où on devait aller justement à la
rencontre des différentes populations
pour pour montrer que la discipline
existe et est là c'est relativement dur
de se faire une place sur lui encore ce
sport se faire une place sur l'échiquier
des sports des sports mondiaux si en
plus ça n'est pas olympique donc
olympiques en 1932 oui c'est un impact
parce que une discipline olympique
seront s'ouvre tout de suite la planète
et là on a tout de suite à un audimat et
une présence médias qui est peut-être
dix fois cent fois plus importante que
le reste de l'année avec l'egypte donc
oui là c'est ça marche ça me rappelle
quelques quelques initiatives que
certains sports ont pris justement pour
aller se faire connaître auprès de la
population
hélène quand on regarde ce sport
finalement ils pourraient être
apparentés la gymnastique regarder les
figures on a vraiment plusieurs choses
entre la gymnastique tout ce qui est
trampoline aussi yann discipline devrait
manquer sur sur le trampoline vraiment
oui le cirque voilà et ça me fait penser
tu vois tu parlais des initiatives de
certains sports voilà pour se faire
connaître
cette démarche que certains sports oms
d'aller vers le grand public et c'est au
niveau de la pole dance est aussi un peu
ça donc je le fais voilà qu'ils aient
cette démarche d'aller vers les gens
pour faire connaître pour développer
c'est vrai que c'est le cas de pas mal
de petits sports voilà un petit peu un
peu confidentiel un peu à très connus
pas très développée qui mériterait pas
ce qu'il ya vraiment des performances
sportives derrière espère
impressionnante au niveau de la
technique vous qui faites de la pole
dance est ce qu vous retrouver certains
mouvements peut-être de pole dance dance
oui alors j'ai fait de la gym aussi donc
la gemmi sportif donc je vois bien
vraiment le bas tout ce qui est laid
gainage les appuyer même la façon de
gérer la vitesse de son corps
l'espace et cetera c'est moi je suis
toujours impressionné en voyant ça parce
qu'il faut une une précision et une
rapidité une endurance c'est quand même
incroyable quoi on est au même titre que
la pole et de la gym oui on est sûr sur
un contrôle qui est presque millimétré
en fin de compte et la résistance des
indics ulation nasa veut quelque chose
il ya dix jours un rebond impressionnant
quelque chose j'en sais un nouveau sport
a essayé pour vous je veux bien mais si
pas mal messieurs je crois que je ne
sais pas pour moi j'ai pas pour être
juste juste des galipettes her way le
petit cabriole open date limite après à
le thème ni un mot de trampoline à
présent c'est l'information insolite du
mois le joueur du paris saint-germain
neymar était mardi en fin d'après-midi à
elancourt le footballeur n'est pas venu
pour signer dans le club local mais pour
faire du trampoline avec sa famille et
ses amis pendant deux heures dans le
complexe au john parkes d'elancourt
ouvert il ya tout juste un an
sur la photo on le voit avec les membres
de la structure
on écoute justement la réaction du
gérant christophe petit plus grande
surprise était pour moi même de
l'accueillir effectivement de le voir
arriver tranquillement
voilà très bien très bonne très bonne
surprise chance à lui il arrivait après
les centres aérés à un moment où on
était j'irai dans une accalmie quand
même une accalmie s'est dit calme
on s'était noël avant l'heure on peut le
dire pour rogers parcours pour la petite
histoire neymar n'a pas testé les
trampolines car il était légèrement
blessé et sûrement pour des questions
d'assurance pour ce joueur qui a coûté à
222 millions d'euros au paris saint
germain
votre avis sur cette venue genre vous
aurait croisé peut-être aux jo mais vous
le fais déjà déjà les mardis sans sa
propre folie les jeux arrêtés mais
north avait six ans après moi ça me fait
rire ça il est venu tout et cognito il
pas eu des colis tôt il a fait les
photos vous en parle ici n'est pas venu
incognito comme moi ça a filtré sur les
réseaux sociaux
non mais je suis bien j'ai bien si ça
lui ça lui a fait plaisir
hélas pas testé le directeur de du jump
ça lui a fait plaisir aussi c'est bien
ça fait de la pub
voilà ça lui fait de la pub c'est bien
c'est pareil part avec des copains ou de
la famille et de toute façon il est par
contre à il doit être il doit être
interdit d'activités dangereuses de ski
de trampoline entre autres donc c'est je
pense qu'il devait plus accompagner les
familles et copains que de prévoir une
petite séance de son père parce que je
pense que damas il n'en a pas le droit
partout où il va aller il y aura
toujours quelqu'un il y aurait toujours
on en parlera donc voilà et puis 220
rôle de les 122 par dont la clause
libératoire de gens me sens également
moi c'est plus ça qui m'étonne en fait
c'est plus de 200 c
alors ça rend les mains aussi un peu
plus sympathique peut-être aussi le voir
aux dérives il reste pas enfermé chez
lui ça toujours été de lille et il est
plutôt connu que comme comme quelqu'un
de jovial de plutôt bon vivant sympa
souriant paraît qu'il était samedi sur
kings los boys cela nous regarde pas on
passe maintenant notre rubrique débats
[Musique]
un débat un peu spécial aujourd'hui
puisqu'on va vous proposer de revenir
sur les améliore moment de sport de
cette année 2010 est dans les yvelines
regardez à ces images et on reviendra
sur ces moments forts avec nos quatre
chroniqueurs regarder
[Musique]
j'ai problème la fiche nvidia minutes
sinon j'aurais déjà et d'évoquer plus
vite
justement et c'est que j'attendais un
peu plus vite et j'ai connu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hp une grosse salle bonne ambiance et je
pense que c'est grâce à 55
aujourd'hui on a réussi et franchement
on avait à coeur de bien faire ici sur
le stade vélodrome et montrer qu on
avait très belle salle à paris
[Musique]
hilali l'organisation d'une grande
compétition internationale au patrimoine
en étant au sein des écuries du château
de versailles
c'est
réussite exceptionnelle
[Musique]
tout
je pense que ça représente énormément
pour le public pour le club les anciens
du club les dirigeants les bénévoles les
petits c'est vraiment vraiment une
grande famille c'est pour tout le monde
voilà c'est pas tout nu s'est accusé du
terrain
un club avec lui ce moment là tous
ensemble
[Musique]
une réaction de joie une réaction de
joie
les jeux olympiques sont à paris en 2024
c'est officiellement officiel maintenant
et là c'est vraiment une explosion de
joie on a senti lors de l' annonce
c'est un parcours de golf fantastique et
d'être le capitaine de cette ryder cup
est vraiment spécial c'est une journée
incroyable avec tous ses enfants je suis
très excité à l'idée de vivre cette
ryder cup à paris
[Musique]
champion d'europe 1
d'ibis grande fierté est encore bien
souvent ceux qui me soutiennent
c'est un objectif terminer on est parti
tant d'autres objectifs encore le monde
[Musique]
et
c'est quand même une première au niveau
national c'est le top
on ne peut pas monter plus aujourd'hui
est donc pour nous c'est un honneur
d'une part et puis on est ravis
d'accueillir toute la france quand le
beau département des yvelines
[Musique]
et
on se propulse donc en appuyant sur les
pédales à l'avant ici le problème
regardez le problème ait dit ça voilà
pour la précision de la conduite du
véhicule etc ça pour pas mettre la roue
dans les trous et puis le frein est
important le fin c'est juste et petit
quand mon tour le guidon comme ça pour
tirer sur la corde et le patin aussi
freiner bloquent la route de temps voilà
ça bloque la voilà voilà le principe
[Musique]
bien sûr il a fallu sélectionner des
moments pour tous les souvenirs de 2017
on n'oublie pas évidemment la montée de
plaisir avec vous aujourd'hui en
fédérale 2 de rugby ont la balise mais
on la vend sun quand même parce que tu
as oublié clients également eu une très
belle place aussi de durand bolitar guy
burton sur le vendée globe pour sa
deuxième participation
mais il fallait faire des choix
aujourd'hui voilà mais bon après on se
souvient qu'en est il de plaisir de
s'affronter
quel a été votre moment préféré de 2017
et ben moi j'aime bien les filles d'issy
les moulineaux avec
da contre brest là et l'autre match de
madiambal way et l'autre match de hand
aussi draveil plaisir la d2 votre jambe
ouais j'aime bien parce que on voit
vraiment que c'est la joie que ces voix
là que c'est aussi une récompense de
gagner voilà j'ai bien aimé ces deux
événements l'équipe de handball de
plaisir qui a terminé deuxième pendant
six années consécutives mais évidemment
il monte et là ils sont actuellement
deuxièmes du championnat de nationale 3
comme quoi
pierre vous inscrire à un moment
particulier qui vous à qui vous a marqué
du coup sur sept mois je garderai je
garderai le jeu garde est par ailleurs
chauvinisme pour mon deuxième sport le
l'annoncent l'annnonce de l'arrivée de
la ryder cup à un an de 1 an de
l'événement et tous les tous les
événements qui ont été organisées à la
fois sur le territoire de saint quentin
puis en région parisienne pour annoncer
ce grand événement qui arrive en
septembre 2018 au golf national
donc ça c'est c'est une perspective
emballante avec tomasz bianchi et qui
foule les faire ou et du national tout
le monde capitale de l'europe est le
capitaine on n'oublie pas qu'ils sont
avérées d'aller au premier étage la tour
eiffel ça s'est décanté menu une image
c'est assez étonnante qui va placer la
france comme comme une destination
golfique et peut-être en plus du
tourisme justement une destination
sportive pour 2018 donc une petite
tendresse pour le nom de la ryder cup
voilà l'événement ryder cup peut-être
c'est peut-être l'événement le plus
marquant on peut le dire en termes
médiatiques vraiment fallait quand même
à vraiment jouer les gardes et robert
marchand et son record que passer sur
cnn bbc et tout autour du monde c'est
vrai que c'était vraiment un record
exceptionnel
c'est vrai que ces différences de
transport qui étaient plutôt des
événements réguliers qui ont été mises
en lumière sur certains points en
particulier de l'année le
la performance de robert marchand ya pas
vraiment déjà de 105 ans et qui font du
vélo
après ce que je me trompe je retiendrai
aussi c'est l'utilisation du vélodrome
on se rend compte que le vélodrome sert
beaucoup même si c'est une structure
nationale à la promotion du club local
du sport dans les yvelines et je pense
que c'est une très bonne chose même si
on regrette parfois qui ait pas plus de
vélos que d'autre chose on se rend
compte que c'est une structure qui est
mise à profit par toutes les fédérations
toutes les organisations sportives pour
promouvoir la pratique du sport chez
tout le monde et c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment un bel outil et une belle
démarche derrière beaucoup travaillent
vraiment salue finalement il ya trois
événements qui sont passés au niveau
international on peut le dire le record
de robert marchand la ryder cup qui est
passé sur plusieurs chaînes à la bbc
s'est passé en prime time
il ya également eu les jeux olympiques
forcément trois événements on peut le
dire vraiment qui ont marqué la halle et
même internationale non c'est vrai c'est
vraiment une année riche en événements
et c'est pas mal ça nous donne pas mal
de sujets à discuter durant l'émission
genre est ce qu'il ya un moment
particulier je sais qu'on n'a pas mis à
jour
mot particulier pour moi forcément c'est
la saison de rugby de plaisir vous avez
passé deux ans à plaisir ces enclaves en
fédérale 2 et avec la montée en fédérale
2 donc pour moi c'est de pour moi c'est
le meilleur moment un sportif après si
loin pour moi ces jeux olympiques pour
la non ce que l'on réalisé les pics en
comme dit frédéric mais ça me donnera
beaucoup de sujets à traiter autour ce
plateau on n'a pas parlé mais le combat
tu as dit la bombe a dit aussi qui a
réussi à conserver à sa ceinture au
vélodrome national un peu un peu moins
un peu moins marquée par sa part cet
événement là
pourtant il a vu son ca comme l'un des
combats les plus beaux de 2017 en france
pas vu pas but my fault peuvent hélas
nous de votre côté à dylan ont 6 6 6 2
il concerne la ceinture européenne c'est
enfin ça fait partie des performances
pour moi que voilà un peu extraordinaire
et après je posais la question de
justement de combat en championnat du
monde
10la qui à 37 ans devrait remonter sur
le ring pour accor on verra mais ça sera
la prochaine étape est déjà le fait
d'avoir conservé la ceinture c'est à son
enfin à son âge il n'est pas non plus
hyper vieux mais voilà c'est ça mérite
vraiment d'être salués c'est une sacrée
performance aussi à 10 la roumanie pour
vous fréquentez recense également un
grand champion cette année 2010 est de
me suivre évidemment après il fallait en
choisir qu'un et puis on voit bien aussi
l'emblème de cantons devront choisir que
quelques-uns alors qu'il ya tellement de
choses qui se passe est tellement de
sujets qui méritent d'être discutés sur
les événements forcément les plus
médiatisées avait aussi la voix la voile
et l'argent récolté pour les enfants à
chaque fois tous ces événements là c'est
vraiment des beaux événements et ça
mérite qu'on en parle et qu'on en parle
plus souvent qu'on le rappelle
régulièrement
justin louis burton aussi vendée globe
vous qui êtes un amateur de voile jeudi
à chaque émission
c'était également un lot de souvenirs
qui n'a pas été mentionné dans le
reportage mais qui a marqué également
les yvelines et je me laisse perplexe
[Rires]
on va passer maintenant au dernier thème
de cette émission on ouvre notre page
découverte coup de projecteur à présence
sur un sport le bridge cette discipline
pratiquée par plus de 100 millions de
personnes à travers le monde se joue à
quatre avec un jeu de 52 cartes dans les
éviers nous avons une prodige ou devrais
je dire un as dans ce sport mathilde
thuillier de villiers saint frédéric qui
est devenue championne du monde l'été
dernier aujourd'hui si mathilde de vie
comme une vraie sportive la joueuse doit
faire attention à son alimentation à sa
récupération avant les compétitions pour
s'entraîner la jeune yvelinoise
participent à des tournois mensuels et à
des parties en ligne sur internet et
pour elle le bridge est un vrai sport on
écoute c'est un sport parce qu'il faut
tenir toute une après midi voire parfois
toute une après midi et toute une
matinée pendant plus d'une semaine et
c'est un entraînement sur toute l'année
et en plus il faut avoir une bonne
condition physique parce que si on est
si on est trop fatigué par exemple on
pourra pas jouer ne pourra pas tenir
toute une semaine de bridge la question
sur ce thème le bridge est il un vrai
sport oui ou non
pour mathilde appuyé c'est sûr c'est un
vrai sport vous êtes partagés offert un
petit duel entre vous et hélène et et
fenech fallait commencer à partir du
moment où il n'y a pas d'activité
physique que je considère pas vraiment
ça comme un sport après ce que le poker
c'est un sport est ce que les échecs
c'est un sport est ce que le shogi au
japon n'en parle jamais ici il faudra
parler aussi un peu du joli joli les
échecs japonaise ça aussi c'est pas mal
de ces professionnels la bataille
d'abidjan
mais oui non c'est
c'est des sports de réflexion est un
sport c'est des jeux de réflexion et
c'est vrai que bien sûr compte dès qu'il
ya de la concentration faut être en
forme etc
mais il s'est passé pas du sport comme
le jardinage c'est pas du sport non plus
et il ya quand même il ya l'effort
physique et les règles codifiées c1
c'est une combinaison des deux est
suffit pas d'avoir l'une des deux
éléments pour pour déclarer qu'on est un
sport je tiens c'est pas et pourtant
elle dit or inteview gilles juste vu que
je suis ce que je pense sur tout mais
moi je suis pas sûr que le bridge sont
un sport olympique d'ici bientôt mais
ils ont reculé en tout cas pour être
sport là tout ils ont postulé tout le
monde peut postuler après voilà que je
hélène
après je pense que c'est
bon sens alors à corps alors en fait je
comprends la notion de l'effort physique
de préparation physique c'est vrai par
contre il ya une telle discipline qu'on
retrouve dans beaucoup de sports en fin
de compte manger et dormir des heures
d'entraînement d'effacer je connais
personnellement une personne qui fait du
bridge mais je ce que je comprends pas
ces cassettes à son âge à elle elle
puisse être à ce niveau là parce que
c'est tellement d'heures et c'est
tellement tout le temps il ya tellement
de règles c'est tellement de
concentration que je
elle a dû arrêter ses études c'est parce
qu'elle fait mais les à côtés elle
travaille dans la médecine allégé
suivante en médecine ouais j'aime
beaucoup
non mais je sais pas voilà l ça fait un
petit moment quel jouet
elle a quand même l'habitude mais pour
arriver en chantant les enfin à être
championne du monde
ça demande tellement d'heures étalon de
de connaissances en fait de toutes les
règles
je suis bon je vais je bien au niveau de
blogueurs et les chaudes mais ya pas de
temps de règles que ça c'est beaucoup
plus complexe le brésil donc que le
poker il faudrait définir en fait il si
la concentration et l'activité cérébrale
brûle suffisamment de calories pour dire
si c'était un sport je suis plutôt jeu
plutôt d'accord avec près de 10 ans à
partir du moment où c'est assez statique
à en dehors de la partie
concentration et l'activité cérébrale
c'est difficile de considérer pour un
sport en comme un sport mais je crois
d'ailleurs que le l'équipe de france
l'équipe de france à des titres mondiaux
individuels et par équipes en bridge
donc là aussi encore une tête une
discipline qui est suffisamment
suffisamment méconnu pour qu'on n'en
parle pas pas tout le temps d'une dire
d'un loisir man was here plus qu'un
sport j'en ai ça vous ne voyez pas
suffisamment bien pierre qu'en donne ses
explications de rome et je sais pour
finir sur une bonne note
parce que
bonjour je vous rejoins mes camarades
fait mes camarades oui je les rejouer
pour moi c'est plus un loisir quand même
à la halle aux sports
mais si ça demande beaucoup de
préparation certainement mais après
quand même il faut que pendant qu'ils à
gérer ceci dit faut souligner assurer la
performance saisies ont pu sied si elles
performent bien continuer personnage je
vois là si ça lui demande le dit
elle-même et leurs vendeurs de
préparation avoir une compétition par
exemple à se couche à 21h30 pour être au
top le lendemain matin
ouais donc ça demande une hygiène
maintenant l'espoir ont fait pas ça non
mais c'est compliqué et c'est compliqué
c'est très compliqué ça revient sur les
problèmes qu'on avait faim de discussion
qu'on avait sur le quidditch on avait
dit que c'était pas vraiment un sport et
pourtant les plus d'activité physique
gpj a encore tiré d'harry potter il y
avait il y avait le 10 sport aussi les
jeux vidéo c'est des jeux vidéo c'est
pas toi t'es sport vidéo alors alors
tomlin juste avant le thème ligne alors
il ya également une définition sur le
sur ce qu'est un sport le une fédération
existe pour du coup le bridge du coup
leur album c'est un sport je pense qu'on
peut rejoindre les actualiser
de toutes les activités qui sont plutôt
des jeux des jeux de concentration c'est
vrai que le bridge est plus côté échec
aux petits chevaux mais échec
non mais voilà tous les jeux comme ça
c'est vrai si on devait nous classions
mettrais plutôt là que dans les sports
physique c'est sûr et puis à côté de ça
tous les le quidditch et cetera ça c'est
plutôt des amusements ya là on est
vraiment sur trois trois domaines
différents registres beaucoup de blessés
durant la saison au prix de pas les
chiffres
voilà en tout cas voilà cent mille six
cents joueurs licenciés en france dont
82 7 % de seniors de plus de 60 ans et
seulement 9 9% de moins de 20 des
adultes
on peut le dire a brillé des enfants
également la chance aussi une activité
qui très vite et très pratique et ça
définit ainsi c'est un loisir ou si un
sport après il ya parlé elle est pas mal
pratiqué par des gens la retraite parce
qu'il faut du temps cette fois du temps
quelques qui ont du temps pour s'y
consacrer tous les jours jean on dirait
un mix entre une chouette et jean pierre
coffe
je prends le jean pierre coffe way sur
cette émission de noël donc cette visée
mission est terminée on se retrouve le
jeudi 11 janvier pour une nouvelle
émission va terminer par une citation
d'un célèbre navigateur eric tabarly
baisser les bras dans une compétition
sous prétexte qu'on ne peut pas terminer
premier est incompatible avec l'esprit
du sport je vous laisse
à bientôt sur tv 78 et de très bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]